Well,
well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
I can't get up.
This is why it is.
You think you're a zero
murder me in my sleep.
You need to tell your therapist about this.
Reactions are funny in those situations.
Do you have problems?
The problems are paralyzed from the waist down and you're dying of laughter.
That was fun.
It's not going to be funny.
MMM,
I can't get up.
Please bring this up in therapy.
Not Normal.
I can't get up.
Basically
paralyzed from the waist down and you're dying.
These are funny in these situations.
This is why it is.
You think you're a serial killer.
You need to tell your therapist about this.
You'd have problems.
It's not supposed to be funny.
Look at the title of the thing.
It's not even funny.
It doesn't say funny anywhere.
I don't know why you're laughing at all.
It's a guy getting run over by a car and you find it a little.
There we go.
Well it's,
he goes,
I can't get up.
Please bring this up in therapy.
Not Normal.
I can't get up.
Please bring this up in therapy,
not Mormon.
Are we
done here?
Is this done?
All right.
Excellent.
That was a Dj Lincolnton with a then Lincoln.
Dan with a,
it's not supposed to be funny of that track.
It's good.
It's really funny.
I think it was pretty great.
Thank you Dj Lincoln.
Didn't Lincoln then think and then um,
just say funny.
Look we are,
we're back.
Not that we went anywhere.
That you went to Disney once.
Oh yeah.
I got some stories for you.
Um,
yeah.
How are we going to move there?
Did you buy real estate there and does ma?
Yeah.
No,
but I actually had really good time,
man.
You did?
Yeah.
Not My experience.
I have a joke on my album about how much I hate the whole state of Iowa.
Yeah,
you do.
Hey,
I'm going to get all these letters from people.
I'm sorry,
Iowa with the,
they live in experience there,
I think at the club.
No,
not at the funny bone.
I did a tour with the Dub David off and we had to drive through the entire state
because the club loves you.
Yeah.
I loved the funny bone in Desmond's actually.
I think it was that tour I did more than the state.
Yeah.
So sorry.
Demoine I took it out on you or Iowa.
Yeah,
but now you can,
you can go back,
man.
I will eventually.
You can go back dog.
No.
Hey Dog.
Hey.
Hey Man.
Hi.
I'm at the Comedy Club Mad.
Hey Ma.
That's a,
that's a dude with a Bluetooth in his ear,
right?
Yeah,
the county.
Ryan sickler is on stage.
All right.
Nice jeans.
Um,
we have little fuck with Lincoln.
We didn't do our dates.
I know we're going to do that.
Oh,
okay.
I thought you were going to go into the clip.
No,
my panicked for a minute.
You didn't think I could.
Uh,
okay.
Well let's do some,
I didn't think you'd remember.
Okay.
When do I ever forget that
this is dreams?
It sounds like dreams by g spot.
And Jay,
are you going to read your dates
or Internet?
Hold on the Internet.
I'm on one,
two,
three,
four.
Oh,
oh,
here we go.
September 27th.
I'm in Seattle technically to come on yet at the to come on your comedy club.
September 28th in Shortland,
Oregon at the helium comedy club.
October 4th Phallus.
Tj Haase.
October 5th.
Poohsticks at,
shh.
It's a secret group.
October 23rd Indian apple tits.
That's right.
Indiana mortise comedy club.
October 24th.
What is Cincinnati again?
Shit.
Pissed,
nasty
shit.
Piss nasty.
Ohio.
Go Bananas.
And then December 9th and 10th,
I'm in Washington DC at the DC Improv.
What does DC stand for?
Yeah,
that's right,
right?
Yeah.
It's music.
A little louder to talk over.
It looks
dumb.
Cunts.
Dcs Analyses.
Yeah,
that's right.
Lazy,
Lazy.
And don't
go to thousand ranch.com for tickets.
No,
you go,
uh,
this weekend I am continuing on the
ball tour in Tay Hos.
Uh,
we got Justin,
we've got
a juice,
then we got moms all Texas dates.
Uh,
and then the final weekend is,
is the following weekend.
That's September 30th through October 2nd,
uh,
the shoreline and Mountain Jews.
Calabar Starline amphitheater in mountain Jews,
California,
Irvine,
meadows,
sperm,
vine meadows,
amphitheatre in sperm,
vine.
And then the final show.
Oh,
this thing is in Fart Knicks at the,
uh,
at the whatever pavilion there.
So the whatever.
Yeah.
Good.
Then there's,
and then nick comes in.
Then,
uh,
let's see.
I have one show only in Ontario,
California,
GM crops,
October six,
one night,
one show.
Um,
then I go to Charlotte,
North Carolina.
I haven't been since,
I think it's been over a year,
so I'm excited to do a weekend there.
October 13 through 15.
Then Cox Comedy Club and Man,
Francisco,
California.
And um,
finally I finished out October at Caroline's on Broadway and Jude ORC titties.
Um,
there's already a sold out show there.
I believe Charlotte and Cox have one too.
Um,
I'm also hitting Raleigh,
Louisville filler up Delphia,
West Falls,
beach,
Florida.
All those tickets are at Thomson [inaudible] dot com go to the show is paced.
Westfalls beach,
those west Harry Palm West Harry Palm.
Okay.
Right?
Yes,
sure.
Last Harry Palms,
West Harry poems.
Um,
all right.
When a wonderful tradition we've started on this show.
Yeah,
it's pretty good.
Pretty good.
Stan,
my fuck.
Oh,
okay.
Guys use our,
uh,
Amazon banner.
Please,
please.
When you do your shopping,
that all that means is you go to our website,
your mom's house,
podcast.com.
Click on the banner at the bottom of our homepage.
It says Amazon on it,
and then you just do your shopping.
If you bookmark it,
that's really,
really easy in that way.
We'll never have to go to our website over.
Oh Gosh,
I see two sluts.
Okay.
You will never have to go and do this every time.
If you bookmark it.
Also check out that seat,
bro.
podcast.com and I think that's all I have for you.
All right.
Uh,
are these two going to talk about quantum physics?
It was probably which one of them won Nobel Peace Prize this time.
You know,
I think it's about the Earth's orbit,
something like that.
Something like that.
Let's,
uh,
climate change.
Let's start the show.
You ready to start the show?
Let's do this.
That's come here.
You know what we have for you today?
A special treat.
They kick you right?
Oh,
it's Ryan.
Don't bring in one.
Loving to this.
Well.
Well go to your mom's house is on
Christina.
Chris.
Okay.
Ah Man.
You know,
I was thinking,
you realize that one of our first really hardcore laughing inappropriate bonding
experiences was a ball kicking video and remember that it was so long ago.
Yeah,
that was funny.
I didn't know I had a love for it until you showed me.
Hey you guys,
you're like,
I want to do this.
I know you've got so excited about it.
Well,
I feel like I could.
Yeah,
I feel like this is the one Shondra of porn that I would really excel kicking
guys in the balls.
It's always amazed me and I think most guys that this is legit a turn on for
some people.
They really,
really,
really want to get kicked in the balls.
If you can conceive of it in your mind.
Somebody doing it right now.
It exists in the world.
If you can think of it.
That video that we watched,
um,
man,
I wish I could find it.
That was from like Brazil.
No,
uh,
it was Spanish.
I think it was like Argentina or something or Ooh.
Why?
Um,
but they had like,
really that girl made that guy believe loving.
That was my fair part.
When she squeezed his balls real hard and the blood was coming out and she goes
Sangria or whatever.
And she kept saying like soup for the soup.
Like she wanted him to suffer.
Yes.
Yeah.
I feel like I could really do that for someone else.
Um,
but only to put that at like,
so the guy that really wants it not,
not well,
yeah.
Someone that these dudes doesn't sign up for this shit,
man.
Yeah.
Really crazy.
I mean,
it's the pain they like.
Yeah.
But you know,
the degradation maybe.
Maybe because there's more to it than just degradation.
There's actual pain.
I mean,
that's very painful to get.
Very painful.
There's even a,
by the way,
a lot of people have told me to download caffeine so that this stops going to
sleep.
I got it.
Okay.
Derek,
download caffeine.
You idiot.
I got it.
Yeah,
I know.
I'll do it.
My got it.
Got It.
I just got home.
Write Right Matt tards.
There's no blue band in the room.
If they're,
if you're wondering why is because our schedule's been so crazy with all the in
and out traveling that uh,
you know,
with coordinating that with a baby,
sometimes we just have to able to run in here when we
have some time.
That's what we want.
Our kid is sleeping or it's harder to coordinate right now
anyways.
Can we watch?
I'm dying to see what happens.
Let's see.
There's,
I dunno if this is a I the dissolve it or not.
I think,
I think this one's okay to play du Du,
Du,
Du.
Okay.
You didn't,
who?
I think that is.
I think that's how does my ass hoe smile.
I think that's her.
Well,
I think you've got a really good ear.
Wow.
Look at you with the porno actors.
You know exactly who does what,
what a talent you are.
Are you proud of me?
Proud?
What a unique gift you have to play.
A girl said what?
But I mean,
that's so proud of you,
sweetie.
I think that's her.
I think you're right.
How does my ass hole smell?
Because she's Asian,
right?
Well,
she's,
she looks Asian slash Asian,
Asian looks Asian is she has that voice.
Had My asshole smell.
Huh?
We got to find that.
Hold on.
We can't move on right now.
My throat hurts and I've,
I've been snoring like a donkey.
God.
Yeah.
I'm real sore today.
Really,
really,
really affecting my instrument,
if you know what I mean.
I know exactly what you mean.
God,
where is that?
How does my ass house smell?
That's pretty good.
Yet
I'm looking at,
I just found on accident.
The reason I like jerking off while licking my girl,
look at my boss from my angle while she's licking my balls,
I'm punching her fucking stupid face.
Wow.
Yeah.
Who she and I might be good at ball kicking together.
Let's see this amazing
had you say as hell.
Okay.
All right.
Hold on.
Yeah.
Do the work.
No,
she's much more girlish.
That's a MILF.
Stick your tongue in my asshole.
That sounds like a 40 plus myself,
like 50 pros
fucking workload and you know,
hey,
you fucking worth it.
Little peak of fucking shit.
How does that translate to sexually exciting?
Exciting for some people?
Because to me,
all I hear is like a,
it's bad childhood.
Like it's not okay.
I have some people that the degradation is what really gets them going,
you know?
Yeah.
Hmm.
I Dunno.
Something for everybody.
Yep.
Same strokes,
same,
same
different,
same strategy.
Same phone.
I think
that is the same.
Everyone is the same everywhere.
Uh,
but you're right.
The thing about,
I mean,
no woman can fully grasp no how awful to 99% of men a ball kicking it.
you've never seen me.
I haven't getting kicked in the balls since I was a kid,
but you know,
the dog can step on my balls and I'll be like,
I'm out of it for sure.
10 minutes.
Well,
or the kid can kick your nuts.
Yes.
You get really mad and it's extremely painful.
I know,
I know.
Yeah.
But it's so weird that nature created that delicate part of you to be right out
in,
in between your legs where they can hit and be,
you know,
and,
and you know,
primitive man,
you used to run through the forest naked.
What if you got your nuts snagged on a twig?
I'm sure it hire a Bushel.
I'm sure it happened.
And why?
It makes me uncomfortable just to fucking think about it,
man.
Running naked in the forest.
Primitive man.
Just to think about ball hitting,
you know?
Yeah.
There's,
there's grazes sometimes your balls can get grazed.
Yeah.
And there's a delay.
Oh,
it hit my nuts.
I'm all right.
And then you're like,
oh.
Like you feel it go up into inside your kidneys basically.
You're like,
ah,
it takes you out.
And these guys are like,
kick me as hard as you can in the balls.
I know.
It's so good.
I know that they hang because they need to be kept a certain temperature.
That's right.
Yeah.
But that just seems so stupid for a hunter gatherer.
To have to run with that delicate package in between your legs.
Let's see.
I don't know.
The La is spread your legs.
Why?
Maybe because you like me.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So
that's her.
No,
she too.
That's her girlish.
Listen to her
fucking okay.
Listen,
listen.
That's hurt.
Hold on.
You got to listen to this am
all right.
Cool.
Okay,
so fucking workload and you not in a habit.
Czech hockey.
Hey you.
Hmm.
Okay.
Okay,
so
hot.
That's her.
Maybe
so hot.
Oh yeah.
Maybe with the fucking shit.
Wow.
Nothing.
What didn't you go on fucking kill yourself now I'm fucking face like,
and I don't fucking need you any more.
It's got like a British English sound to it.
Like she learning.
Yeah.
Hot.
Yeah,
you're right.
There it is.
It's the British.
Yeah.
He'll fucking bitch
Tommy my okay.
Wow.
What a good ear.
You have master of accents.
You truly have earned your,
your award today.
Your Medal of honor for that one.
I am so proud of that.
I didn't know this clip was coming by the way,
so I can really claim my throne today.
Wow.
Someone's got an ear.
Yeah.
Good for you.
Good for slack chatter.
We're not going to get to see it.
Um,
let me see.
I Dunno.
Get up against the law is spiritual lives.
This is,
yeah.
Come on.
Let's see it.
You want to see some ball kicking?
Yeah,
we'll just have blue blur it or something.
Pixel it.
Well,
some of these,
let's see if there's any clothed ones,
because sometimes they do it with clothes on and sometimes,
but that's no fun.
Or you want to see it naked.
Oh,
of course.
That's the funnest part.
Okay,
well,
let's see.
I don't get to see the jiggle.
You know why you fall to the ground is even better,
I think.
Oh.
Oh,
that's it.
This is a special one.
No,
that's the guy though.
Oh,
right.
That's why this looks familiar.
Yeah.
Really?
No,
she's not fucking around.
It just makes me laugh,
but he,
he enjoys this so much,
so absurd.
Why would you enjoy this?
It's so weird.
No,
my life.
Oh No.
Jeez.
Of like,
oh,
this feels good.
And then
give it a kick.
Yeah.
All right.
Now Open your mouth.
That's happening.
Cots.
Jesus Christ.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
What happened.
Naked like this is fully naked.
Isolate for the youtube,
but you can't deny the listeners.
All right.
Oh my God.
To see it.
I see this.
Yeah,
I'm ready.
All right.
Uh,
uh,
it's just a painter.
This feeling,
is she missing teeth or their teeth too?
Really feel it.
Doing Balkan before.
Got a lot of cues from Scott.
A few missing there.
I don't know what thought.
Yikes yet.
God,
that is just so painful,
man.
Yeah.
Not For me.
Not for you.
Huh?
I mean I would do it,
but I would want to receive it if I were a boy and I don't have the standard Mo.
Oh yeah.
This is another thing too.
This is a kicking or needing the balls as the guy orgasms.
Oh,
let's see that one.
Jesus,
you're really on a tear today.
There's ball stomping.
Well,
cause it don't,
you need your nuts when you're
the guy gawking yeah,
you do.
Let's kind of,
I guess the pain wouldn't that
you would think so?
Huh?
You would definitely think so.
But this is scientist.
You really want to see that.
Yes.
God.
What's wrong with you?
Why you want to see this?
Okay.
I want to see almost,
oh
yeah.
Jerking himself off.
She's Naomi the balls.
See,
that is so ridiculous.
God is,
how does he come with that pain?
You don't think you think that the body couldn't do both at once,
you know?
Oh.
Then there's the,
uh,
there's people that really getting bays like smack the balls room.
Oh
God,
this looks so painful.
It looks so painful.
Yeah,
I see it.
Ooh.
Ooh,
Or He's on all fours and she could gotcha.
It sounds like the three,
doesn't it?
Wow.
You know why I like it so much?
I feel like it's the easiest Gig in porn.
Yeah.
You're,
it's just chill.
Like,
Oh,
you want me to kick a dude's balls for 20 minutes?
How much money does that to get paid to it?
That sounds like a
real blessing.
That in the fart videos.
Oh,
I say that's like the easy way out of porn.
that's what you're going to do.
Um,
you know as soon as I get off the road here,
you know,
oh we're going to do this together or we're going to do porn.
No,
no.
You're going to do ball kicking and fart videos when I'm off the road.
Right,
right.
Bring generates.
Yeah.
Get,
get your own site started.
Probably easy.
Ah,
so easy.
Oh who cares,
my mom's dead.
Doesn't matter.
There you go.
You don't have anyone else in your life.
So who fears God?
I'm just looking at,
there's so many of these.
Okay.
Just pages and pages,
pages,
all that interesting costing,
ball kicking.
Oh Man.
I saw one of these once where um,
they were doing the video and the girl was kicking him,
kicking him and they had to get a replacement guy cause she,
I think like ruptured one.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
It isn't there a massive health scare.
I mean,
I can't imagine what a urologist would tell you if you're like,
so I'm doing,
if I'm,
if you're a guy and you're like,
I haven't signing up for these ball busting videos,
right.
Punched and kicked in the balls and they'd be like,
ah.
Well cause I've heard of guys where they're nuts flipped and they twist
essentially.
Right.
And that's very painful.
You don't want that to happen.
That can happen real easy doing this.
Yeah.
It happened during a baseball,
he was squatting down to catch a baseball and his nuts twisted around.
Oh yeah,
they flipped.
There's uh,
there's one here where a lady's got on boxing gloves
and I think that a guide we live in,
the big guys like the star of,
of,
you know,
I think he's,
he's the guy.
He's a hero in that world.
Yeah.
Cause then they can't be too many out there.
I also imagine that if you shoot those,
um,
you,
you also have like weeks off between them.
You know,
he got it.
Yeah.
To recover,
right?
Yeah.
This video's is called,
I bet you he can't come with broken balls.
Who gets to title the videos?
That's what I wonder,
man.
I don't know what a great job this is.
This is so painful looking though Jesus.
All right.
Try that line.
Maybe you can try that line.
Okay,
let's go.
I want to hear it again.
All right,
hold on.
Here we go.
Maybe because you like being kicked in the,
oh,
that's really good.
Yeah.
You have to do it.
I guess the law is spreadsheet.
Do a bad,
yeah.
We can't be too sincere like acting right yet.
Get up against the wall.
Spread your legs.
Yeah.
It'd be like over the top with it because you're going to be so good at this.
That's why I'm just going to keep him nice and hard.
Right in the balls.
That's why I'm getting kick it nice and hard.
Remember that HBO thing,
that girl that did like the,
the behind the scenes,
you know,
like the sex answers.
Remember on HBO is wonderful.
Kate,
Katy Perry,
Katy Perry hosted this thing.
I'm on Hbo and she was like,
yeah.
The thing about pornos you just,
uh,
it's like yes.
Ending,
right?
Yeah.
That's good.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'd be real mean about it.
I don't think I could fake the,
the joy.
I just be like,
coming me,
fuck,
fuck boy.
You know,
I think they would like an ear scam.
Fuck these guys like definitely like the GG Allen School of yeah,
these guys were like fucking dummy
fucking dummy.
There you go.
Oh,
she's got it down for sure.
Um,
I had a lot of fun and uh,
one thing,
excuse me,
that I got to do.
Where is it?
I had it all queued up.
Stand up.
Stand them up Stan.
I've actually had to stop using that word because I can't figure out if its
stamina or making fun of it.
Yeah.
I was trying to make fun of it too and I thought I was saying it wrong.
If it's too close,
yes and no,
I,
I fucked it up.
I have to hear him say it to know that that's wrong because now stamina sounds
wrong.
Like stamina,
stamina.
It's like when we made fun of all those words and then it gets stuck that way
regardless.
Library pacifically pacifically stand them up.
See what standing with sales right now to me when,
uh,
we were looking at homes,
one of the ladies that was showing us a home goes,
I go to this room,
be,
she goes,
you could use it as a library.
Stand them up.
I had a lot of fun in the Ma and then I even got to go have some fun on the
morning.
Yeah.
Oh it's a garage or a DJ?
Dad Mouth.
Aka duct tape.
Duct tape.
How'd you get that?
People call me duck tape man.
Cause I always have it on me.
You know,
like macgyver.
I'll duct tape your mouth shut.
I'll just,
anywhere that you have a hole on you,
I'll put duct tape.
So I'm going to do it up tonight.
I didn't realize that morning.
A lot of color options.
Duct tape.
Is this a guy thing?
Is that we just adored duct tape so much?
Or what,
what is the fascination with,
with tape?
So this is a jail thing.
Really dancing.
Oh please,
please tell us.
Warm.
Just a buddy of mine,
he got locked up for armed kidnapping and then he,
uh,
everybody had like a nickname in prison and he found some duct tape so they
called him doc tape.
I'm just trying to,
I want to free my buddy duct tape free doctors.
Free Duck tape.
Free Dog.
He for awhile he has,
you know,
it's a 20 year sentence,
but the thing is there's good behavior and there's appeals and if everything
goes right,
I think duct tape,
it'll be out in seven free dog tape.
Here's the thing,
I feel like if you commit armed kidnapping,
but it's during a drug deal that it's not like,
like there was other people doing bad things anyways.
They should give you a little bit of leniency on that.
You know,
it's not like he kidnapped a kid.
He can't have a bad dude.
So he essentially,
it took someone off the street,
they couldn't find chewy for like,
I don't know,
three weeks or something.
So that's three weeks that she wasn't selling a cocaine.
Here you go free,
dark yellow.
Yeah,
of course.
I got a dog.
I put it in her purse.
Stay tuned folks,
because we have got to do,
got a duck tape,
something to follow you on Twitter at,
at to grow.
And I will tweet out the location of the after party and we will wreck a place.
We will physically destroy this place out.
Duct tape it all back to yeah and that's exactly what I do man.
We tear it down and then I put it back together back together.
Man.
You get my home's concept.
Someone's never been to your show
besides duct tape.
What can people expect?
Not like an x rated show,
but it's like all rated.
It's probably are rated for adults to come out and have a great time over a
drink some food and enjoy your crazy thing.
You're going to switch your name to scotch tape and not know duct tape.
No,
no,
no.
Cause I'm going to honor duct tape until he gets out.
Free doc tape free or your comic mentors.
Like who did you look up to as a young kid?
And he's like,
you know what,
someday I'm going to do that.
Uh,
it changed,
you know,
like when I was like a young,
young kid,
I feel like it started off with a Cosby.
He's got a little bit of legal trouble himself.
He should get some duckies in bubble wrap and some duct tape a long time ago.
No,
you should not have had decayed
thanks a lot for those crimes.
Uh,
I then I liked the TPM away from the duct tape.
Not,
not here.
Keep Cosby away from the duck tape.
It's all kinds of things going on here.
There's a lot of good comedians
like free duct tape,
duct tape.
Go ask the day.
Alright.
There you go.
How long was that?
Did that feel super long?
What do you mean the video with them?
Yeah.
Oh,
talking to them.
I did it half an hour with them.
That,
oh my God,
that was,
that was edited down to three.
Hilarious.
I also did the weather going to,
we have a weather video.
Okay.
Let's see.
Um,
were doing the Lord's work on these morning shows,
you know that right?
Really Fun man.
Yeah,
they're just so unwatchable until you come off.
Um,
I wish you did all morning shows.
It's really fun to,
Oh,
we gotta talk about Corey Feldman going on the today show.
My God.
Yeah.
Do you want to see whether first,
yeah,
of course.
I did some weather stuff.
Where is that speaking of inappropriate though on morning shows that Corey
Feldman thing was fucking,
that was crazy.
Yeah.
Oh,
I'd never thought duct tape would be so giving,
you know it's crazy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Hey everybody.
Welcome back Cwi while I'm worried.
Sure.
I'm James Peterson back on my side here in front of the weather wall with duck
tape.
Mr Secura.
What's that man?
We wanted to come and pee.
He wanted to come in front of the chrome.
Well,
he's ever stood in front of a green walls.
A few folks at home don't know this is called a chroma key green screen green
screen.
I'm gonna let,
we'll let him do the weather.
I'm going to step out of here.
He's got to tell you about the rainfall.
Let's talk about rain real quick.
Man Over here in Cedar rapids here maybe gotten a little over and it says
nothing.
Spencer,
man,
y'all are wet mess.
So easy.
What does this deck,
Decorah.
Dick.
Cora.
Cora,
they're not even no rain or they use,
just felt lazy.
You didn't put like putting into the total is Waterloo.
There's other places I got duct tape for decor.
I'm not going to put on the wall but here I would cover this up
cause you guys disrespected the Cora and you also disrespected Davenport.
Yeah.
And let's see what else we got.
We're going to,
we're gonna show the Skycam.
Oh Sky Cam.
Oh look at this.
We'd like to thank our sponsors at or in homes.
If you're looking for a house and you have money contact or in homes and they'll
help you get it.
And if something breaks,
we'll put duct tape on.
It is currently 63 here and the conditions are fair,
somewhat sunny,
cloudy.
You watch this,
watch this little trick was this bullshit shit.
If you're sweating,
it's not helping matters.
93% humidity.
It is muggy outside.
The winds are coming out of the west,
southwest around six miles an hour.
If you don't have duct tape,
make sure you pick them up today.
It solves so many issues.
The core is not there on this one either.
While they're having technical issues,
the technical problem,
the technical,
it is a good idea to bring out the duck.
Yes,
you could.
You could duck tape over them and we'll just get back to that.
Might have blue gaffers tape.
Here's your future tracker.
All refugee tracker.
I'm gonna put,
I'm a let you play with
Chicago.
There's water there and the Minneapolis is snowing very hard right now.
And also in Kansas City there's a lot of snow in fire.
A future trackers,
letting you know that there's some rain and mixed in other things.
Uh,
or in homes.
Doesn't sponsor this segment.
Anything else?
All right.
No,
we're gonna walk back over here.
Dr Tape.
Very good.
Yeah.
Very Fun.
Dj Dad Mouth.
You did a really good thank you that you should do that all the time.
It's fun to do morning news when they're fun.
They really let you have free reign in Iowa.
Huh?
They were fun.
Yeah.
Those two were really good time.
That was.
That was definitely fun.
See,
now I like I,
oh,
I changed my mind.
So you have a good time there.
Yeah.
Does that make you not want to go on as yourself though?
Yeah,
I'm not sure what I would do now if I,
if I were go on those terrible shows,
you know?
Yeah.
Don't call their sheer terror.
I mean really awesome,
relevant
hip veggie doing work,
doing the Lord's work.
I used to bring fif on television with me just then they,
they got a real kick out of seeing the dog.
But I don't know.
I don't know if I could do a character.
Let's see.
A,
you want to see,
oh my God.
So it says,
oh my God,
there is late.
I'm sorry you sent me this thing when you sent me a Corey Feldman.
Oh fuck.
Well my friend Mary Lynn texted me first thing on,
I forget,
maybe Friday morning,
Saturday morning.
And she's like,
have you seen this yet?
And I mean the Internet exploded with people and I feel like we don't usually
touch these big important stories.
Yeah.
You know?
But this was so weird.
Like,
I feel like we need to really get into it and analyze what is happening here.
Yeah.
Uh,
cause so Corey Feldman went on the today show and he's been making music since,
you know,
the late eighties,
early nineties.
Did you know that,
that he went on,
um,
like Howard Stern's television show and sang a song in 1992 about like the youth
of today and stuff.
It was so weird.
No.
So you know,
he's a,
you text that to me or did you think I texted it to the world?
Yeah,
I texted it to everybody.
Or was that a text?
Yeah.
Okay.
Anyways.
Um,
so hey,
I just got a phantom tax.
You know how you get them to yeah,
I got one the other day too.
What is your say?
Mine says is,
is this someone trying to reach dean?
My old Stepdad.
I Dunno.
Huh?
Can I finish my,
oh,
sorry.
I got one that's the other day that says thanks.
We finished 10 minutes ago.
Smiley face.
No,
no clue.
And then did you write back,
how hard did you come?
I should have.
Why didn't I,
it would have been great.
I mean,
I fucking miss my shots.
So anyways,
Corey Feldman,
his mentor was Michael Jackson.
We all know that it's here.
Yeah.
He was a celebrity kid and he hung out with Mj.
By the way,
did you hear that?
Someone came out and finally said that Michael Jackson did sexually abuse him as
a child,
but because of the statute of limitations on it,
they can't press any kind of charges.
There's a statute of limitations I think you need limits on,
I know,
right?
Yeah.
But the guy said that he was,
you know,
I dunno why he didn't come out so long.
I imagine the shame of being molested and,
and whatever the feelings.
But,
so the guy finally came out and said that yes.
An MJ.
What he would do is have his assistant reach out to these families.
Yeah.
And be like,
Hey,
do you want to come hang out at Neverland?
And then he would,
you know,
show them the roller coasters and all the cool stuff.
And the parents would hang out with Mj and he would win their trust.
Kind of like,
you know,
oh,
isn't it great?
And then he would have the assistant reach out to the parents and ask if their
kid could come to Neverland and spend the night.
Right.
And then these idiot parents would let their kids spend the night with Michael
Jackson.
Of course he was molesting.
Doesn't it seem crazy now to think that people were like,
no,
he's not doing that.
Of course he's not.
He just likes to sleep with young children.
He just likes to sleep with little boys like he's just a kid at heart.
No,
I chose you to how people let logic go when someone's really fabulous.
Well,
when they really love Mike,
I loved Michael Jackson.
They love him because he's so talented and famous by saying,
yeah,
if he just was like,
Oh,
you're that Guy Michael.
He works at the craft store hardware,
sleeping with kids.
He'd be like,
yeah.
All right,
well he's going to spend the night with your children.
No,
no,
he's not.
Or you having a hard time finding this?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
do you want me to find it?
Press pause for a minute.
Yeah.
Right.
All right.
We're bad.
We got it.
Um,
oh man.
Buckle up guys,
if you haven't heard this,
this is Corey Feldman on the today show on the today show.
And by the way,
you can see like even at this point,
yes.
The Michael Jackson influence,
you know,
you can see the insanity ramping up.
Like you can tell that Cory's off.
He's got a hood on like a dark hoodie and you can see the look in his eye isn't
normal.
It's not normal.
It's that Michael always had like very distinct,
uh,
and white and black was always his thing.
You know,
like a,
and you can see that that's,
that's what he's going on coming here.
I felt like the cover Angelica or
is him coming out of the earth wearing black and there's fire and there's
angels,
but it looks
Jorge Angels.
Right.
But it also looks like $2 cover art,
like at the mall.
Do you remember,
you probably weren't into this,
but in the 90s when um,
like that there was,
there's this southern Shondra of hip hop really exploded all their cover
harmony.
No,
that's not southern
thugs.
No,
it looks like it looks like what?
Like,
um,
like uh,
making say,
uh,
like all those guys,
they're covered.
Ours was like tanks and like just I guy in a goal like juvenile and them and I
can't even think of his name,
but um,
wait,
wait.
But you know what?
I like it.
This is like gang banger art where it's and Jelly number two,
that Gore and it's got that like,
yeah,
handwriting font,
whatever that cursive font.
It looks like it was made at the mall,
Dude.
Yeah.
Here's the master p album covers.
Okay.
Like,
yeah,
here's this is,
that's what I'm saying.
All those looked like that back in the 90s.
And the angels are dressed like prostitutes.
They got garter belts on.
They all dress like sluts,
sled angels,
like the Halloween Costume version for women.
This is like what all these,
oh right,
right.
Yeah.
That's a lot better.
Well
I,
it's hard to describe but if there was a lot of fire and flame,
it's like cheap shit.
It's like a dude just learned,
not even like whatever was before Photoshop when they were like,
hey put a tank in there.
But that's a fire to fire in there.
It's,
it's that bad.
It's really fair.
It's worse than that.
It really is.
It is garbage.
But if you're,
if you're debuting like a hip cool song is the today show where you do it?
Well you do it when you're a pop star.
All those little like Katy Perry who does those pornos and like,
uh,
um,
you know like uh yeah whatever.
Whoever the famous singers are Dave,
they do these morning cause they know there's millions of viewers.
How did he get on here?
Do you think you had a publicist or somebody,
obviously there's some hookup where maybe somebody saw it and they're like,
do you want to see something go viral for the wrong reasons?
Well that someone the book or got fired immediately.
I Dunno.
Maybe promoted cause think about how many views the thing,
here's the thing,
the music's not that shitty.
Like how is that any shittier than the shitty things they play on the radio.
That's just a shitty as anything else.
I think it's the,
it's the dancing.
It's like,
you know,
in a six year old is like,
Mommy,
mommy,
watch me dance.
Mommy,
look,
look at my dance mommy.
That's what he's doing.
Yeah.
Where it's like,
look
at,
look at my dance moves,
mom,
watch me dive three,
dive mommy.
And I was like,
I'm watching,
I'm watching you.
Yeah.
Um,
I already can't do this.
What's going on?
I Dunno.
So there we go back here.
I wanted to pull up something else to show you at the same time as this was
playing,
um,
here,
maybe here I can do it,
but there's cause it kind of a,
it kind of made me reminded me of something else.
I also like the host who's like,
uh,
I had a Corey Feldman poster on my wall.
Like,
wait,
you're a dude though,
unless you like dude's did you have other dudes on your wall growing up?
Really?
Doesn't this give you a little bit of a reminder of
[inaudible]?
It's just a Shitty,
is that,
yeah.
I mean,
which the Shittier,
oh,
definitely.
Uh,
Nick Hawk,
I think they cock is the worst
is
yes.
Not that's what I'm trying to say.
It's not that shitty.
It's not that bad.
No,
you just heard it.
You'd be like,
Eh,
it's an a,
it's not,
I mean,
I'm not going to buy this,
but I'd be like,
it's all right.
But the absurdity is the dance and that it's him and the dancing.
The dancing is outrageous.
He even is rocking.
What ended up being a Michael Jackson style of hair.
You realize that?
Yeah,
but I mean Michael Jackson rock that there was a point where he had long hair.
He combed it back here.
We kind of pinned it back and then less some loss.
It's a direct style suck.
But he's like,
that's my idol or whatever,
you know.
But very much Korey always chose late eighties MJ versus the early to mid.
I always thought this was Mj is least attractive era.
I like shorter heaven later.
This is like a lady.
Yeah,
mid nineties look like black or white.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Yeah,
he really,
and the reason I think so many people made fun of him after this,
besides how bad it is,
and you can tell how sincere he isn't it.
But I like that.
So I know.
No,
I'm not faulting him for it.
But when you see someone trying really hard and it doesn't go well,
then they go,
they come in on your heart.
He probably has been just tortured since this.
Well,
you'd think that and you'd think that he may throw in the towel,
but he hasn't.
And like he's been shit on a lot.
[inaudible]
wings,
angels,
they love that Shit.
But he tweeted out,
he's like,
I guess you know,
everyone's talking about us.
I guess the angels and I did our job.
Like he doesn't,
I dunno,
there's something here that says it's really not going out going well.
Oh really?
Cause Corey Feldman sobs,
aw.
While speaking out against today's show reaction were petrified to even go out.
And he says it's the experience becomes something to hide.
Like I think there's a video of it.
It got,
let's see.
He has not been able to get out of bed after the person.
Oh No.
Yeah.
This is this fifth album.
I know.
That's what I'm,
that's what I'm thinking is that maybe it's time to,
you know,
throw in the towel here,
man.
This is,
um,
Ooh.
Well,
what's going on here?
What,
what do you think is,
well,
how does this happen?
Is what I'm trying to ask you from a,
an emotional,
did a Facebook live posts responding to his critics?
Oh,
doors now infamous performance on the today show.
Friday he debuted his new song,
go for it,
and the appearance received a bit of backlash and is now deleted posts.
He said,
quote,
all we can say is that we tried really hard because we love our fans and we just
wanted to give them the best show that we could,
but we don't deserve these things that are being said about us are awful.
Feldman was a popular teen actor in the 80s he started in the Goonies and the
lost boys.
Wow.
There you go.
You know what I think it might be because he got famous so young that it's like
kind of an arrested development thing.
Like he stopped developing it like six years old.
Yeah.
You know,
and he's kind of stuck in this
age.
Yeah.
It says,
um,
it is delusional though.
It is delusional and I dunno,
I mean,
I think you know what the other thing is too is that you can almost blame the
today show.
Like if he had just made a video for this or something,
it wouldn't,
yeah.
But he's on the today show.
This is like part of it.
Like they fucking,
this is the thing where they go,
oh,
Rihanna has a new thing.
She's going to do it on the today show.
And they put him in that series.
Wow.
That's really weird of them to do that.
You know,
he said it's been really painful.
I don't,
sorry if it's not good enough for you,
but you don't have to beat us up.
Well look at us participating in the beating up.
Well,
yeah.
It was just such a shock.
It really was like such a weird thing for me.
Yeah.
It was just like,
what do you,
I don't know man.
What's happening?
Yeah.
No,
it's really bad.
This is really bad.
Yeah.
Um,
the dancing is really good.
We see more dance moves.
So I liked the dancing.
Yeah.
He's doing his,
uh,
his,
his little,
yeah.
I got to play the song.
Oh,
okay.
I thought you wanted to mute it to not to not shit on him for Oh,
there if you were trying to dance like Michael Jackson.
Yeah.
And they would teach you in stages,
you know,
like,
well,
let's first do this.
He's doing like stage two,
right of,
of learning how to do it right now they're light,
right.
They're clearly amateur.
Michael,
like entry level moves.
Yeah.
He's like,
he loves Michael Jackson.
He can't do Michael Jackson moves.
Yeah.
So he's doing,
you know,
little things that our dance class,
yeah.
It's like he's,
you could see the little moves.
He just,
all the stuff and Michael Jackson did.
Thank you.
That's totally MBA stuff.
Yeah.
All of the
foot.
Yeah.
But he does it like a six year old.
Right,
right.
And that's not a doing Michael Jackson.
That's not good.
Wow.
That's so interesting.
I don't want the guy to kill himself or anything,
so no,
it is just give up music,
hang out,
just give up your dreams.
No,
that's terrible.
It must be hard to have this desire in you so much.
Like I want to be a singer so bad,
but you're really terrible at it.
Yeah.
And you just keep failing and failing,
but then you,
you listened to the secret or you listen to Tony Robbins and they're like,
keep going no matter what.
And he was like,
yeah,
I'm going to keep going.
Maybe not throwing the towel,
you know,
um,
moving right along.
Yeah.
Can I ask you your advice on something or can I pick your brain on something?
So on a Friday I had lunch with a friend and I had a kale salad with salmon
and then I had violent diarrhea for like the next day I just had really hot,
sour diarrhea.
Are you listening to me
anyways?
Here's what I noticed happening.
Are you paying attention?
You have to pay attention to me.
Look at me when I'm talking to him,
please.
I was pooping and it was really hot and it burned a lot and I noticed that every
time I'm done making diarrhea,
I have to pee.
It's lot a lot like the yellow,
brown,
yellow phenomenon,
but this time,
every time they have diarrhea,
I have to pee afterwards.
Okay,
but why?
I mean,
I dunno.
I think your body's just getting rid of everything.
How has that weird?
I don't understand.
It's weird because when I sit down to Brown,
I make pee all the time.
Like I already pee before Brown,
so I'm empty,
but then why would I make the area?
There's always a yellow there.
I'm sure it's really good question.
I'm going to call a doctor or something.
I do.
You don't have that.
Maybe that's just a girl thing.
I think maybe you're right.
I think maybe you're just so focused on when you have diarrhea,
it's more like your brain's like,
oh shit,
this is real,
you know,
not normal.
Then maybe you hold your pee a little bit and then when you brown that out you
relax more and your body goes,
No,
let the pee out too.
I feel like it's something to do with heat.
Your body losing he or something.
This is a really interesting,
this is the thing,
you're like,
hey,
let me bring this up.
They didn't want to tell me earlier.
You're like,
I got something I got to talk about.
That's it.
That's really good.
But I'm serious.
You're not taking it serious.
I'm taking it really seriously.
It's maybe it's your loss of body heat and then like the peak gets made.
Yeah.
Um,
Oh,
you know what?
Uh,
it may be that,
isn't it?
It's really interesting and I think we should explore it more.
Maybe some other time.
Um,
but I don't think it's heat leaving your body.
I feel like my body heat leaves when you have diarrhea,
you know?
Can I tell you the worst thing you've ever done?
Yeah,
I wrote it down.
Okay.
You called me the other day as you were eating veggie chips from the trader's
Joe.
Yeah.
On speaker phone.
Yeah,
that was terrible fly.
Just horrible.
I was hungry.
I hated it.
The why.
What was terrible?
I Dunno.
The sounds the sounds.
Yeah.
That sounds where you were on speaker phone.
So how could you even hear it so much here at amplified?
What do you mean?
How could I hear it?
It was amplified.
It sounds like you got really mad.
Yeah.
So
it sounded like on speaker phone it was so terrible.
I didn't have the stand up to,
to naughty.
I'll tell you,
say it correctly.
You mean stamina,
stamina,
fan of that.
The right way to say it.
Stamina,
stamina,
stamina.
Sounds wrong now.
Salmon.
That does sound round.
Yeah.
Fuck Stamina.
Stan [inaudible] Fatima,
you know what you did Dan ma CNA.
It sounds bad when Steven says it.
Yeah.
You did something gross this week to uh,
we were hanging out with the dogs and you were sitting on this chair and the in
our bedroom and you called bitsy over.
Yeah.
And I knew it was coming cause I saw you pose for it.
[inaudible] you farted on Betsey's head but your legs were spread open.
Here's kind of suggest that I sat on,
here's how it was.
I was sitting in a chair with my legs open.
Right.
And then she put her paws up like to come up.
So she's,
she's standing on the ground.
Her paws are on the hair and her face is basically in my open crotch.
Yeah.
And I felt like I was like,
this is going to be a good one,
you know?
And what did she do?
She might like,
it was like I was awesome.
Where's that from?
That was great.
Yeah.
Cause bitsy loves the farts and then faith does,
faith doesn't like the smell of fire.
If you fart in your feed,
he gets up and walks away.
Doesn't like farts.
Fevers.
So into self preservation.
He knows like when the baby is going to pull his hair,
he just takes off.
Busy doesn't get it.
Nope.
He didn't even tell exactly what causes that counterpart Bitsy,
uh,
had her beard pulled yesterday by Ellis.
Yeah.
So hard that she cried.
Oh,
her ear on her ear.
She hasn't learned yet.
Those Fif sees that baby.
He's like,
I'm out and never going to get my hair pulled.
So you farted and Betsey's face your face.
Yeah.
And it was neat because I got to witness and I saw the ramp up.
I knew what you're going to do.
Yeah.
And I was like a
read just totally degraded now and to just being frat boys with each other.
Like do you not want to be romantically associated with?
Absolutely.
Of course I did.
It was just such a good opportunity.
I didn't know how to pass it up.
And you had on boxers too.
So there was only one layer separating bitsy from that fart.
And if I could,
if I could explain a little more.
I had a,
a meaty kind of rich lunch and then I came home and I made fitness.
Oh.
So they were extra like,
you know,
I dunno.
They were extra cooked up in right there where the system was going.
Yeah.
So I had felt a few like really good ones leading up to the,
I knew it was going to be good.
Yeah.
You knew it.
You felt it in your heart?
Yeah.
Now how have your bowel movements been lately?
You haven't,
I heard it this morning.
It didn't sound good.
Did that was,
that one wasn't great.
But aside from that one,
I didn't know you heard that one.
I can always hear,
oh,
that one wasn't good walls for say hearing.
It wasn't very nice.
But aside from that,
it's been really good.
Your Diet's been better.
And when is your colonoscopy?
It's in a next month.
It's an October.
I think I'm gonna have to have a good day.
I'm traveling on the date it was scheduled.
You got to do it,
but it's cleaned up since you've changed your diet a bit.
I know you haven't been eating fried foods or many carbohydrates,
so that's an interesting thing to note and no sugar.
Yeah.
Except yeah,
to this morning it kind of went stop what you think.
Except except for this morning the Brown sounded really explosive.
Yeah,
I think
it was,
um,
you know,
just like that early morning,
food made a,
I was on an empty stomach.
When you eat on an empty stomach and it has any richness to it,
you know,
still happen.
Yeah.
It was interesting.
I went to silver lake,
uh,
to have lunch with a friend and it was like taking a tour of all the restaurants
from my past and I got diarrhea from.
Yeah.
It's,
it's interesting how many places on the east side.
I,
I used to get diarrhea from.
Where did you end up eating any more?
Good Little Dom's.
It used to be a French place.
Uh,
I can't remember the name of it.
Love who bell?
No,
no,
us on what street?
It's on a Hillhurst and you know,
our Mexico City,
that restaurant is,
I've got diarrhea.
There are so many times Mexico City mixed Mexico gives me diarrhea every time I
would.
And I still eat there.
I've got Mama.
You guys,
don't you miss that?
You guys would give me a lot of farts.
But that's my absolute favorite Mexican place and all of Los Angeles.
As you guys in La,
in Los Angeles.
But that is the best.
Yeah.
That is a little stand.
It's a,
it's a stand in a parking lot and a bearded Mexican lady takes your order and
writes it on a bag and you eat in a filthy parking lot.
Yeah.
And like birds take shits next to you and it's the best mood.
She's a big lady.
She's Harry too.
Yeah.
Makes good tacos.
It doesn't really make him,
but she sets out,
she sits down and takes,
or it's her recipes,
I think.
Yeah.
But it was like a tour of everywhere I gotten sick.
Cafe Stella.
I remember we took Maria there years ago.
Yeah.
And she got diarrhea in the bathroom as we were eating their players.
Blair's give me diarrhea.
Really?
They did the collywobbles.
Oh yeah.
I really liked them,
but the,
that made me sick every time.
A lot of risks.
Food is just really rich to come with a lot of butter and restaurants.
So can we talk about the why Goo?
Oh my God.
Get your life.
I know.
It was really good.
Best thing I've ever had.
Me Too.
It's like buttery.
There's American Wagyu and there's Japanese Wagyu and the Japanese stuff is like
eating a stick of butter.
Yeah.
There they purposely encourage you to get small portion of it
cause they know how.
How rich don't need a huge one of that.
Oh my God.
Like every bite.
Just
how do they get it?
So they do,
they force feed it like Kobe probably like beer,
feed it and massage the calf or whatever.
Is it a cat
fatty?
I Dunno.
I don't even know.
It's delicious though.
Yeah.
That was real.
A special treat that we,
we,
we went out,
we don't really go out to eat that much anymore.
I used to love to do that.
I said all the time before baby jeans.
Yeah.
But you know the kid sleeps at seven and by then we're just so tired.
All we can do is watch,
you know,
an episode of flipping out on Bravo TV and then I fall asleep by nine.
I go to bed even much earlier now.
I went to bed at 11 last night.
Oh Wow.
He used to be up every night one too.
No.
And if you left town I'd be like backpack.
No,
five 30.
Ah,
yeah,
you were a real night owl now too tired.
I'm exhausted.
Every damn exhausted to the bone.
You had your beard trimmed.
Hmm.
You can see it if you're watching.
It's much shorter.
Um,
and it was cut a week ago.
So you can imagine,
dude,
I,
I had to get it.
So here's the thing,
your beard starts to get really thick.
You don't just throw the trimmer on it,
right?
Because your hair starts to grow on your face.
Like it went on your head.
Meaning that it's better to have a professional trim it because when you're
talking about long bushy hair than it's growing in different directions and
different lengths.
So,
but when you have a pro do it,
you know,
they'll comb it like you,
they would your head and have and shape it like you would your hair.
So my guy is awesome.
He's the best and he's added town last week and it's getting my,
my beard is getting like to a degree of mountain man that I can't even,
you know what I mean?
Like it's Farrell,
it's too,
so I go,
can you recommend me somebody?
And he goes,
yeah.
And He sends me this dude,
good guy,
pro guy obviously.
And I just don't give them any,
it's my fault.
I don't give him any heads up.
Like he just goes,
oh,
what's going on?
I go,
oh,
this thing's out of control and a,
I don't want to just throw the clippers on it.
And he's like,
Nah,
you need,
you need someone to shape that for you.
I go,
yeah,
he doesn't ask me much more on.
He's like,
all right.
And he starts doing all this stuff that I'm used to this guy doing,
you know,
combing it,
clipping it with clippers,
like,
or with scissors,
like you would head hair.
And then I go,
yeah,
down here,
I don't know about,
you know,
pulling it up something.
He goes,
Oh yeah,
you don't want a line.
I just kind of blended in and I go,
okay,
he throws his clippers on like when you hear the one,
I'm like,
yeah.
And then he just goes
and clips it all off and I was like,
uh,
and you can see it go down.
Right?
Like,
you know when they're fucking you.
Yeah.
Like you know it's happening,
but you're like hoping against hope.
Maybe this guy knows what he's doing yet.
Maybe I should just hang back a little and not panic.
And after like,
um,
uh,
something really dramatic,
you know,
you can't go,
oh right.
It's too late to like,
let's just see where it goes.
Yeah.
It just keeps going and going.
And I'm like,
oh my God.
And to make it even worse,
I even go like,
Oh wow,
this is really different
and what I'm used to.
And he's like,
Oh yeah,
yeah.
It just,
it turns almost the whole thing off and you have to act like you do.
Love it.
Thank you.
Wow.
Yeah.
It goes different,
but it's fun to see different looks.
It is fun.
Well,
you came home and I was like,
well,
it's like when you had those replacement teeth.
Oh my God.
That was the worst dude you got.
Fuck.
Like he fucked your beard so bad.
It's a little better now.
It's way better.
It's grown a week.
Yeah.
I mean your,
your beard grow so fast.
Thankfully that it wasn't too long looking like a dick.
But Dude,
that guy jacked you.
Yeah.
We got to yell at Allen.
Allen sent you there.
No,
we don't need to yell at him though because like I said,
I could have,
when he said how's it going or what's going on,
and I was telling him I could have said the normal thing,
which is,
you know,
it's way too big.
I want to bring it down some.
Yeah.
This is what you should say to a new person.
He doesn't know me at all.
I should have given him some direct.
Explicit.
Yeah.
I was just like,
yeah,
it's long.
And he just went at it and he was like,
let me let me fuck your shit up.
You want to look stupid?
I was like,
you look stupid.
God,
why stood up?
I was like,
man,
this looks like shit and that doors and then you can't really,
you can't express your sadness cause like you just,
you just know you're never going to go back there.
Yeah,
of course.
It's a loss.
It's a wash.
Talk about it.
You're like,
hmm,
maybe we should just cut the whole thing off right now.
I considered it for a moment and I was like,
well there's still some there so it's probably better to not trim more.
In other words,
it'll catch up
ELAC quicker.
It grows so fast on you.
Yeah.
I,
you know,
I went to my regular misuse and uh,
she's like,
do you want to try Reiki?
And I'm like,
yeah,
I asked her,
I go,
does it feel nice?
She goes,
yeah,
some people think,
think it feels nice.
You know,
I wanted a massage.
Really.
I didn't want to try Reiki but,
but I kind of roll with it.
Yeah.
Anyway,
I absolutely hated it cause it's like one of those things where they just touch
you,
they touch your shock rose or whatever the fuck.
And I fell asleep.
I went through phases of sleep,
anger,
rage,
like stop fucking touching me,
like just fucking rubbed me like,
let's go.
Yeah.
And I really like her and you know,
we,
we just decided to try something different,
so I had to pretend like I really enjoyed the Reiki.
Like she goes,
did you love it?
I go,
yeah.
Thank you.
Oh,
I loved it.
Yeah.
What a neat experience is that thing too?
It's like just being right,
right?
Yeah.
I had that once in a hotel where I call the spa going to deep tissue and then I
get in the room and it's like this frail older lady and I'm like,
so you do deep tissue,
Huh?
And she's like,
that's not really what I do.
That's what I booked.
She's like,
wait til you experience what I do.
Like just touching your like tickling.
Yeah.
Gentle touching.
And I was like,
ah,
my seven year old girls do to,
what do you think?
I'm like that I think I like it more fresher.
Well,
sure.
Yeah.
Well
I know,
and she goes,
uh,
so I see her later.
The reiki lady.
I saw her like a couple of weeks later
and she's like,
so how did you,
how did you feel a
breakthrough?
Did you have any weird dreams?
I was like,
Oh yeah.
Oh,
it was so good.
So weird.
Thanks.
Hi.
I can't even tell you because she goes,
you're going to have a spiritual enema.
I'm getting,
this is like a spiritual I and I was and I thought,
well that's two things I love.
Yeah.
I like spirituality and I like shinning,
so.
Yep.
I'm on board.
You thought you were ready to go?
I thought I was in for a treat.
That is your wheel house.
Oh,
I know.
Yeah.
And then I got,
I got real disappointed.
I got real angry.
Yeah.
Angry you if you try Reiki.
No,
I don't want to.
I know.
I don't like it.
Go ballistic.
It's so horrible.
I don't like any of that life.
Oh.
I always like whatever strength you have,
give it to me.
All of it.
She literally just touched my,
yeah.
For like 15 minutes and then I'm going to,
she touched my heart in my chest Chakra.
Just touched it.
And then I'm going to,
and I was like,
ah,
fuck.
I wanted to river.
And
I do like being kicked in the morning.
I'd rather get kicked in the balls into Reiki again.
Yeah.
Fuck that was
and raging.
Yeah.
And it went on for so long.
It was a full hour of just soft touches that for an hour I Dude,
oh,
that's terrible.
That's terrible.
It's too long.
If I want to take a nap,
I could have stayed home.
I made a nap.
And your and your table man.
Shit.
You know what I'm saying?
We have some,
you know what I'm saying?
Is here,
I think it's,
you knows,
it's Lorens Larkin.
Let's see,
he's a free agent.
What statement do you think you made tonight with this performance?
Um,
you know,
I think I made a pretty big statement.
You know,
I'm not even ranked,
so I couldn't tell you if even if there was ranking from one 15,
I can tell you where I was at.
So I think it just shows a lot.
You know,
I took the fight on short notice and,
uh,
you know,
I've,
I finished them and then in the first round,
you know,
and,
um,
I don't feel like it was a lucky shot.
And you know,
I think it was just right from the get go.
You know,
it's sticking to the game plan,
lot of,
you know,
where I was out of division,
you know.
Yeah.
You know,
it's not like I don't,
you know,
I see stuff on the,
on the media and the Internet,
you know,
and comments,
when,
when UFC post stuff and bypass was posting stuff.
And I see the comments of fans like,
you know,
who is this guy?
Who is he?
Um,
and you're a big,
big proponent of separating,
you knows,
you know,
what I'm saying is you feel me,
I'm talking about,
so this guy would be in his own,
you know,
category Lorens Larkin.
Let's see,
a super cut of all his,
um,
you know,
we know that,
I mean,
you know,
and you know,
I'm not known,
you know,
and you know,
you know that,
you know,
you know well,
you know.
Yeah.
You know,
when you know,
you know,
uh,
but you know what I'm,
you know,
I'm partial to,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
I like,
you know,
so,
but uh,
to me it's really,
it's this,
the special thing is,
hey,
you know what I'm saying?
Cause it started that way with us.
We we liked,
you know what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying?
Yes.
I'm talking,
you feel me?
I'm saying
try fact that you feel me.
You know,
it's
unreal,
man.
I got a good joke for your dad.
Really?
Well,
I told it to you.
I don't want to,
I just got to write it down for next time.
For Your Dad.
Yeah.
Tell him this one.
Um,
let's see here.
There's that.
There's,
wait,
can I bring up a dad thing real quick?
Then?
Of course.
Remember,
um,
were you here when my dad,
no,
you weren't here.
My Dad came to visit with my cousin Julie,
and he was watching Ellis play on his little thing that he runs in circles on
this little toy.
Yeah.
And my dad goes,
you know,
uh,
pretty soon you're going to have to start hitting him.
I go,
well,
he's like,
yeah.
I mean,
you know it.
He's going to get a little older and they get a little out of line.
You sometimes you just got to hit a kid.
That's what they tell you.
It's good.
He goes,
Doctor Tony Grant used to say this,
you have to hit the kid.
Why?
I was like,
oh thanks.
I don't even hit,
I don't hit anybody in my life.
Right.
There's no one getting it up right now.
The dogs,
I don't hit anybody.
Yeah.
And if,
if,
if I'm not hitting you where the dogs and it's working out,
I think we should hit him.
No,
this is the one time I'm going to say we shouldn't listen to your dad.
He's got a great parenting advice,
but did you get hit?
Uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
Not like now.
I mean,
there you go.
No,
but he would give me,
he'd spank with my parents were spankers.
They would hit me with a wooden spoon.
The fuck are now is what they call it.
Hungarian.
A wooden spoon and spanx.
Yeah.
My Dad would spank my ass as a kid and he gave me a cookie.
Did I tell you this one?
When they knocks your head a cookie.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I really like knock your head.
It's really terrible though.
I would never do that to a kid.
It's very demeaning.
Speaking of,
uh,
you know what I'm saying is,
do you remember the song?
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
I go with crew.
It was really good.
It's so dope.
You don't say
same.
Right.
You know what I'm saying?
Mom.
Mom,
mom.
You don't say yes.
Same French accent us.
You know what I'm saying?
Like some mayor of know what I'm saying,
mayor,
you don't say
proper.
You
know what I'm saying about my dog barks?
Anyone understand that?
That's fraud,
but it goes crew.
They made that song.
Unreal,
man.
It's really good shit.
One of my favorites.
Wait,
did you get hit by your parents?
Nah,
man,
they're not spankers.
They spent my mom me a few times and like her third time she,
I laughed and she was like,
whatever.
Yeah.
That's always the key to getting hit as a kid.
If you start laughing,
then the power's gone.
By the way.
You want to see something amazing that somebody sent in?
Uh Huh.
Gracious spot.
Okay,
here we go.
This is pretty great.
What did they find that
this Yay three reseller
is he skinny.
Wrestler is fast.
It's great.
I said,
I said
is
awesome.
Holy Wow.
So great.
That's really fantastic.
And he just said,
don't worry.
I know Bert.
Bert did.
Yeah.
So good.
I love when they involve the children,
school children,
and I know we've had a couple
full of those.
Really amazing.
So good.
Amazing.
Um,
oh,
I guess it's Japanese kids.
I think that's it.
Oh,
Burt grizzler.
Yeah.
Thank you.
That's another one.
Burt Greenler.
Thank you Johnny Scotch for sending that in.
Oh,
I have some,
a couple of submissions of horrible are hilarious.
Would you like to,
yeah.
All right.
Let's see if I'm Burt crushers.
Fat Fat.
This is any good here.
But Dad
gum.
You uncle buddy.
Yes.
He needed
somebody on a motorcycle.
So he h
where staying on telephone?
Hello?
It got funny.
So this is a thief.
He um,
he was stealing something.
Well then hilarious.
I mean I like,
he goes,
yeah.
A Napier de is not a Fart as my leg here now.
Yeah,
I liked it cause that's how they teach you in Spanish ideas.
Me.
Oh,
and I can last [inaudible] nobody.
I don't think anyone ever said those words.
Tj K gross.
Someone's home.
The shut up.
And he was just like,
my life fucking hurts so bad.
Okay.
Oh He's,
I didn't assault anybody.
You faggot.
I think he assaulted someone.
Stole something damn thing crashed like this and how his legs off fucked up.
Yeah.
And your legs all fucked up.
God,
his leg might be really fucked up.
Yeah,
it looks like it's bent the other way.
It doesn't look good.
Ooh,
Ooh.
Oh yeah.
I'm just seeing that for the first time.
It's all,
oh shit.
Yeah.
It's like stuck in there and then his body's turned that way.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
So he was was trying to get away from his robbery.
You know?
Imagine that you're going to come back
and as you're going through that,
people are talking shit to you.
Yeah.
He kept it on.
They're all yelling at him.
What did they say?
What does that mean?
[inaudible] covered on that is like,
you know,
fag asshole.
Good.
Yeah.
That's why I love Latin.
It's like they don't,
they don't give a fuck.
He's like,
I ain't got it on like there.
So they're so a chill like so real about,
so chill.
I'm serious.
Like Americans are like,
we can't do that.
You couldn't call someone a faggot it even if they stole something.
Yeah.
Well there are,
they don't have to treat them with dignity.
Like,
no you don't.
If it's a thief,
fucking gets hurt.
That's on him,
dude.
You're fucking cub it on now.
You know what I'm saying?
That's funny.
Get Bueno covered on how good,
like,
you know,
that's great.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Dude,
same muddy.
Gone there.
They're really,
oh,
Susan.
Some real pain.
It sounds like
I'm a poor guy.
Oh my God.
Yes.
It's offensive.
So what happened?
But these must be,
he wrote,
he drove into something like the site and that's what this he and he took it
with them in other words.
Right.
With the,
with the power of the motor.
Yup.
And that's what Ben has let Jesus,
man.
Hmm.
Anyways,
it's very funny.
Um,
yeah,
give that hilarious,
funny.
Yeah.
That's really good.
Plus I lived the other dudes talking shit to him.
Yeah.
That's kind of my favorite part.
It was pretty good.
Yeah.
I enjoyed that.
Like,
come on Faggot.
Hold it together.
This master of accidents came in with a translation.
You want to try it?
It's actually,
yeah,
yeah.
Familiar.
We've seen it before,
but we didn't play it as a master of accidents.
We just played it.
Um,
I'll show you,
you'll recognize.
Oh yeah,
sure.
Do you want to shine on TV yet?
Let's say you want,
you want some?
Yeah I bet I got you want some,
if he wants to only give it to you.
Debbie died during my,
their,
yeah,
and the guy looks like he's about five [inaudible] three maybe 130 pounds.
Yeah.
So you're just shit out.
That's what it says here.
You're just shit out.
You've got no fans
that I don't know what you don't know.
Durant.
Yeah.
You don't know Duran Duran?
Oh,
the band from the eighties yeah.
No Dry.
Yeah,
I think so.
Yeah.
Simon,
the bones,
my favorite singer.
Yeah,
that's what he's talking about.
Yeah.
You think you're good?
You guys have fans,
but no one here knows what Duran Duran.
Hey God,
no fun.
Rio is my favorite song.
Oh yeah.
That guy says the fucking hawks are playing well and then the guy goes,
he wants them.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Yeah,
you want to sell?
So he said,
uh,
well the hawks are playing well,
which I definitely did that get,
oh sure.
It was great.
I don't know what the fuck he say.
What do you
give it?
Yeah,
they're winkers little.
I got that.
I got that wasn't,
but there was a little bit of of a nonsense.
They're drunk.
Jibberish drunk,
he's kind of a t two a little,
a little drunk.
Aggressive man is the best.
So cute,
cute little guy in a fight.
And I was like,
aw.
Like even that guy is being a little like,
oh,
that's cute.
Little drunken English look drunk.
Four adorable outcome.
Um,
I was thinking about maybe a new uh,
exercise program.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
let's see it.
It's called Mama clean.
I've tried over a thousand ways to make my life manageable and quite frankly,
I maxed out exercise to me has always been a priority,
but it was always at the expensive of dirty,
gooey kitchen or hundreds of Aaron's left undone.
And I finally,
I got so fed up that I worked out a quirky slightly off the wall that'll system
where I can get it all done at once.
Okay.
She does like homemade.
The Clean Mamak program is an element of three days.
Kind of like a triangle.
On one side of the triangle you're going to have your multitasking exercises
that I'm going to show you.
And how to really maximize on the other side of the triangle.
You're going to have your diet.
Now don't confuse the word diet with something short term.
You get the idea of what she does,
right and then,
and then it's like workout while you're cleaning stuff
a,
which I suggest you do at least three times a week.
It's creating your own personal boot camp style and just really knock it out.
I know she's a real go getter.
These poor women,
this is the best she with her camera thinks this is a really great opportunity.
So he's a construction worker working outside and approaches him about lifestyle
changes.
You know
the second way
got to come on.
[inaudible]
no,
that's the wrong clip.
That's the wrong clip.
Take a look at what I gathered from around my house.
I clip is not the one
like how much smaller my tits were bad.
Here we go.
Look,
how much
do you ever have time to go to the gym?
Is your time while you are doing your daily routine,
what do you do?
Breaking.
So I'm going to show you how to rake so that you could really get a good ab
workout in.
You want to learn?
Yeah.
Likes that.
There's a part of this guy that definitely thinks there's,
um,
he's gonna get it later.
Yes.
That's the only reason he's honking or say what?
Yeah.
I liked the task of size.
Whatever she says.
He's like,
yeah,
I love it.
I think he went to the same beard trimmer.
You did.
All right.
I need somebody to hold the camera though.
Can I hold your pussy?
Yeah.
He just wants to here,
take the rake over here.
Here we go.
Now rake some leaves or whatever.
And really use your stomach to pull it in.
Use Your Tummy.
Tuck a cigarette while you do it.
Okay.
The littering is not what we promote.
God doesn't give a fuck.
Okay.
Right.
Do your ranking.
Great video quality.
Sound great to ask the guy who rakes to [inaudible].
Well,
I didn't gate and use your stomach.
Depaul
feel a difference.
Yeah.
Oh,
see that?
He's like,
this is what I do.
She's like,
do it.
Do you feel a difference?
Yeah,
no.
What I want you to do is hold this DVD.
Yep.
Oh my God.
Turn it around and say,
Hey,
mama rock.
Yeah.
Can you suck my Dick?
Why don't you approach the guy that looks like he already works out?
Maybe like not that guy.
That guy doesn't want his abs touched at all.
Oh my God.
He totally thought he was going to get with her.
That's the only reason those dudes talk to you.
Feel.
Get my balls kicked right now.
Oh,
I can help you.
Yeah.
I'd love that.
I'd love to kick some balls.
Yeah.
That's why I'm staying nice and hard balls right in the bottom up.
The files that you know,
be good at that as Maria.
Thanks.
So she would really sell it.
Yeah,
I think so.
It's pretty good idea.
Um,
all right,
James,
you got anything else?
Nope,
just love in my heart.
Um,
thank you guys for listening to your mom's house podcast.
We'll be back at your mom's house,
podcast.com thousand ranch.com for tickets to see Christina Thompson,
[inaudible] dot com for tickets to see me and believe you with a chopper man.
Chop Dawg song and uh,
we'll see you soon.
Thanks guys.
Bye Mommy.
So I wanted to read some jokes to you and you tell me what you think of these
jokes.
Okay.
How can you tell when a blonde sends you a fax?
Ah,
I love blonde jokes,
by the way.
I don't know.
It has a stamp on it.
Love it.
Okay.
How can you tell if a blonde has been using your computer?
I don't know.
There's whiteout all over the Monitor.
Yeah.
Why do blondes wear panties?
Okay.
I have no idea.
They keep their ankles warm.
What did the blonde say when she saw the sign in front of the Ymcas?
I don't know.
Look,
they spelled Macy's wrong.
This is one of the best conversations on my life.
I love just laughing,
Tommy.
I Know Dad.